on the top floor of a library in
Manhattan there's a secret apartment and
it's been left empty for years I'm Sarah
Glasgow
I'm a senior writer at Alice obscura
this is the secret apartment at the Fort
Washington Library in Manhattan
[Music]
back at the beginning of the 20th
century Andrew Carnegie gave the city
5.2 million dollars to build libraries
all over the city they all look a little
bit like this one with these big
sweeping windows that are supposed to
keep the building's light and cool
downstairs it looks like pretty much any
library upstairs though it's a
completely different place someone who
works for the library once told me it
feels to them like being in a haunted
house even walking up the stairs you can
sort of feel that there's this water
stain coming down one of the walls and
the stairs are pretty but they're dirty
and there's this like white plaster
falling from the ceiling the first thing
you see when you get up there is this
big room and it would have been used as
a public space maybe for like lectures
or meetings or dances but the really
cool surprising thing here is
it's pretty much a dream to live in a
library right I mean at least for me the
first time I came here it was creepy the
light switches weren't working so it was
really dark and we had to watch where we
stepped because they told me the floors
weren't really safe but one of the first
things I noticed was how bright the
walls are I mean whoever lived here
wanted to make it feel welcoming and fun
it's a pretty big sweet apartment I mean
I think most people that I know in New
York would be really happy to live here
you can just feel what it would have
been like in one of the rooms there's a
mirror and I can imagine standing there
and then just checking what I look like
before going out I did get to meet
someone once who lived in an apartment
like this the buildings were heated by
coal back then and the custodians had to
keep feeding the furnaces all day and
all night and since they had to be
available all the time it just made
sense for them to live in the library so
these apartments were built for them and
for their families too now there are
just 13 of these left I mean this is an
enormous amount of space to go unused
right in the middle of New York City and
when the buildings stopped using coal
and the custodians retired the library
would just shut up the apartment but now
they're trying to repurpose all this
room by converting the apartments to
public spaces if everything goes
according to plan the library will
repurpose this apartment too
and you know everyone I tell that to is
disappointed because there really would
be awesome to live here
[Music]
thanks so much for watching if you want
to know about more amazing places like
this one subscribe to our Channel or
just click to watch more videos in the
comments we would love it if you would
tell us about your dream apartment and
where it might be located